u.s president donald trump has repeated
unsubstantiated claims of voter fraud on
the eve
of a crucial senate runoff election
taking place in the state of georgia
trump made the claims at an election
rally in dalton georgia
in support of two republican incumbents
trying to fend off a strong challenge by
democratic rivals
u.s president-elect joe biden also
campaigned in georgia
he told voters they could set the
country's course for a generation by
electing
two democrats to the senate
well tuesday's special election will
determine president-elect biden's
chances of pushing his agenda through
congress democrats will soon hold the
white house
and the house of representatives but if
republicans hold control of the senate
they will block biden from pushing
through many of his policies
here's the balance of power in the
senate right now where republicans
currently have
50 of the 100 seats a democrat and two
independent allies hold 48 seats
democrats
need to win both of the georgia seats
with vice president-elect kamala
harris's tie-breaking vote in the senate
that would effectively create a majority
of 51 for the democrats
well let's take a closer look at the
contestants in that georgia runoff we've
got
two democrats john ossoff and rafael
warnock
they are up against two republicans
david perdue and kelly luffler well dw's
oliver sonnet reports now from georgia
on this crucial vote
it's people like julius hall who the
democrats are now pinning their hopes on
he's among thousands of activists
getting out the vote across georgia
african americans might be the decisive
force in this runoff
how you doing all right we're all
canvassing the area trying to get
everybody to get out and vote
we've been behind so long in this
country um
and so when you get a sense of you're on
the rise
and things are happening where where
there is some inclusion
and then you get a clown that takes
office for four years which is donald
trump
now we get rid of him and we feel like
we can
start over again
[Music]
john ossoff is one of two democratic
candidates it's a race the 33 year old
senate hopeful must win
for the democrats to gain control of
congress
in american history the stakes are high
and so are his goals
establishing health care as a human
right in the united states
investing in clean and renewable energy
to create
jobs and solve the environmental crisis
passing a new civil rights act to secure
equal justice for all
regardless of race the runoff is a big
opportunity for democratic hopeful jon
ossoff in his attempt to unseat the
republican
incumbent david perdue but the runoff's
remain a neck on neck race in georgia
has been a republican stronghold for
decades and john ossoff knows
the fate of the biden presidency lies in
his hands
[Applause]
on the republican side senator ted cruz
wants to stop
congress from certifying biden's victory
he's under fire from democrats for his
push to throw
out the election results and he's
rallying for turnout in georgia
the people of georgia are gonna rise up
and say hell no
i've got faith and confidence in the men
and women of georgia
i think the people of georgia believe in
common sense values
they believe in low taxes low
regulations and lots of jobs and i think
the people of georgia want to see a
check
and a balance on the extreme left wing
former trump campaign manager corey
lewandowski took the stage among several
other big republican names like former
senior white house advisor
kelly and conway but the spaces remained
half empty
after weeks of baseless claims about
voter fraud
some conservatives are skeptical about
the electoral process
all of us are concerned that is our vote
going to count
does it matter because i really do
believe that
just like with the national election
there is a chance that they are going to
be able to
manipulate the dominion software
machines again
you're in gwinnett county georgia right
now i've lived here for 30 years
and there is no way on god's green earth
that this county went
democrat in the general election
less republican turnout more democratic
turnout
a scenario that activist julius hall is
hoping for
on election day
let's bring in stacy bivens here from
our u.s
elections team stacey this runoff
election
in georgia is happening under
extraordinary circumstances not least
because
president trump is still seeking to
overturn the results
of the presidential vote what impact is
donald trump having on this election
race in georgia
donald trump trump's presence and his
rhetoric is problematic for republicans
in georgia right now he's been attacking
the secretary of state and tried to
bully him into
coming finding 11 000 votes he's
attacked the governor and promised to
campaign against him in a year and a
half this is forcing democrat
republicans to decide
are they going to stick blindly with
trump because he has such a strong
base or are they going to say enough is
enough we've had an election
the election is now over it's time to
move on and it's time to focus on this
rat
on this race but in this rally
donald trump was really focused still on
himself and on trying to
rewrite history which was the election
and he cannot do it and it's causing
problems
but it's also his rhetoric is also a
boost to
democrats who are more than happy to
listen to him
talk about trying to strong-arm the
secretary of state
so it might boost uh democratic support
but his
rhetoric with republicans might suppress
the republican vote
because as the woman said in oliver's
piece can we trust that our vote is
going to count this is how republicans
are feeling some of them
these senate races in georgia are hugely
important everyone agrees on that
tell us exactly what impact they could
have
in the u.s political context well
they'll determine how effective joe
biden is going to be
as president if it's a
white house run by democrats and a
congress run by democrats it'll be
easier for him to get things done
when it comes to covet health care the
economy the environment
it'll be easier for him to get his his
uh cabinet picks because
those aren't set in stone just yet these
are people he's nominated but they have
to be approved by the senate
and so if uh these congressmen the
democratic congressmen win
um senators prospective senators
win their race then it will be easier
for them because the democrats will
will have the majority with kamala
harris casting the
um the tie-breaking vote of course the
democrats have to win
both those seats in order to give biden
that control
it's a big ass in georgia is
traditionally a republican stronghold
what makes democrats think they have a
chance of flipping those seats this time
i think hope i think when you look at
also at the map of what happened at the
election that some states that were red
turned blue including georgia and i
think that these candidates give them
hope um
john ossoff was a protege of the late
great
um i just forgot his name
of the late great john lewis who risked
his life
fighting for civil rights for all of his
life
and uh reverend uh raphael warnock
is also important because he is an
activist he's well known in georgia
and he's a minister at the same church
where reverend dartmouth
dr martin luther king was minister so
there's this hope
by this grassroots organization that's
been registering more black and brown
people
that these two candidates will attract
more voters to the polls
very exciting race uh we'll keep
watching stacey bivens from our u.s
elections team thank you so much you're
welcome terry
now to some of the other stories making
news around the world today
the head of the far right group known as
the proud boys
enrique tario has been arrested in
washington
police say he was involved in torching a
black lives matter banner
taken from a church during protests last
month
he was also charged with possessing
illegal high-capacity firearm magazines